AND GOD BLESS.
>> THANK YOU.
YOU AS WELL.
SO BACK NOW TO OUR STORY HERE IN
UKRAINE, RUSSIAN OPPOSITION
LEADER AND PUTIN CRITIC ALEXEI
NAVALNY SENTENCED TO NINE MORE
YEARS IN MAXIMUM SECURITY IN A
PENAL COLONY.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO RUSSIAN
STATE MEDIA.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT CALLING FOR
HIS IMMEDIATE RELEASE AND
CALLING TODAY'S DECISION A SHAM
RULING.
HE WAS CONVICTED
HE WAS CONVICTED OF FRAUD FOR
ALLEGEDLY STEALING FROM HIS OWN
ORGANIZATION.
NAVALNY APPEARING IN COURT TODAY
LOOKING FRAIL.
JOINING ME IS RUSSIAN OPPOSITION
MEMBER AND CHAIRMAN OF THE HUMAN
RIGHTS FOUNDATION AND RENEW
DEMOCRACY INITIATIVE.
THANK YOU, GARY.
WE APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US.
PUTIN'S SPOKESMAN TELLS CNN, AND
I QUOTE HERE, NO ONE IS AFRAID
OF HIM.
IF A PERSON IS A CRIMINAL, HE
SHOULD BE IN PRISON.
BUT WOULD HE BE GETTING NINE
MORE YEARS IN PRISON IF PUTIN
WASN'T AFRAID OF HIM?
>> OF COURSE HE IS AFRAID OF
HIM, AND HE IS SO AFRAID THAT HE
NEVER EVEN MENTIONED HIS NAME.
PUTIN BELIEVES THAT MENTIONING
NAME OF ALEXEY NAVALNY COULD
ACTUALLY BRING SOME EVIL TO
PUTIN'S WIFE.
AND I WOULDN'T BE SO CONCERNED
ABOUT NINE YEARS OR TEN YEARS OR
FIVE YEARS.
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS.
NAVALNY WILL STAY IN JAIL AS
LONG AS PUTIN STAYS IN POWER.
SO IT'S AMAZING THAT MORE TIME
NAVALNY TIME SPENDS IN JAIL, THE
MORE CRIMES HE COMMITTED.
IT'S AN AGONY.
IT'S A DESPERATION.
PEOPLE MARCHED PEACE INFORMAL
THE STREETS OF RUSSIA.
OR IN JAIL LIKE ALEXEY NAVALNY.
BUT I THINK THIS VERDICT IS A
DEMONSTRATION THAT PUTIN IS
ENRAGED WITH HIS FAILURES IN
UKRAINE, AND THEY JUST TRIED TO
TAKE REVENGE ON SOMEONE WHO IS
STILL WITHIN HIS POWER.
>> GARY, I GOT TO TELL YOU THAT
NAVALNY'S FINAL TWITTER AFTER
THE SENTENCING WRITING "NINE
YEARS, WELL, AS THE CHARACTERS
OF MY FAVORITE TV SERIES "THE
WIRE" SAID, YOU ONLY DO TWO
DAYS.
THAT'S THE DAY YOU GO IN AND THE
DAY YOU COME OUT.
NAVALNY HAS BEEN VOCAL EVEN AS
THE KREMLIN TRIES TO STIFLE HIM.
DO YOU THINK HIS VOICE ALONG
WITH WHAT IS GOING ON IN
UKRAINIAN WILL CAUSE PUTIN TO
GROW INSIDE OF RUSSIA?
>> LOOK, I DON'T THINK THAT AS
OF NOW WE CAN EXPECT THE MASSIVE
PROTEST, THE REVOLT THAT COULD
THREATEN PUTIN'S POWER.
IT HAPPEN ONLY AFTER MILITARY
DEFEAT IN UKRAINE.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
SUPPLY UKRAINE WITH ALL THE
WEAPONS THEY NEED TO WIN THE
WAR.
NOT JUST TO SURVIVE ANOTHER DAY,
BUT TO WIN THE WAR.
THEY NEED LONG-RANGE MISSILES TO
HIT RUSSIAN SHIPS THAT ARE
SHELLING THEM.
UKRAINIAN VICTORY AND PUTIN'S
DEFEAT IN UKRAINE MAY LEAD TO
REVOLT IN RUSSIA BECAUSE
DICTATOR CANNOT AFFORD LOOKING
WEAK.
AND THEN NAVALNY WILL HAVE A
GREAT CHANCE OF LEAVING PRISON
BECAUSE DURING THIS CHAOS, I
THINK MANY, MANY THINGS THAT
PUTIN'S DOWN, THEY WILL BE
REVERSED.
SO THAT'S WHAT ALWAYS HAPPENS
DURING REVOLUTION.
BUT AGAIN, THE NUMBER ONE
CONDITION IS MILITARY DEFEAT IN
UKRAINE THAT WILL SEND A MESSAGE
TO ALL PUTIN'S CRONIES AND
HENCHMEN IN RUSSIA THAT HIS
REGIME IS WEAK AND IT'S GOING
DOWNHILL.
>> NAVALNY HAS BEEN HELD IN THIS
PENAL COLONY PRISON SINCE
FEBRUARY OF LAST YEAR.
AND BEFORE THAT, HE WAS POISONED
WITH THAT NERVE AGENT.
YET EARLIER IN THE WAR, HE WAS
TRYING TO ORGANIZE
DEMONSTRATIONS USING HIS SOCIAL
MEDIA.
PUTIN SO FAR HAS BEEN UNABLE TO
SILENCE HIM.
WHY IS THAT?
>> LOOK, IT SEEMS THAT NAVALNY,
AND OF COURSE WE UNDERSTAND, IF
PUTIN WANTS IT, NAVALNY WILL BE
SILENCED FOREVER.
IT'S EQUAL CREATING A MARTYR.
AND I THINK PEOPLE AROUND PUTIN
RECOGNIZE THAT.
NAVALNY IN JAIL IS BAD, BUT
NAVALNY MURDERED IN JAIL IS EVEN
WORSE.
AND I ALSO THINK SOME PEOPLE
AROUND PUTIN, THEY'RE ALREADY
THINKING ABOUT THE FUTURE.
DICTATOR'S POSITION DOESN'T LOOK
AS SOLID AS IT USED TO BE.
AND I THINK THEY WANT TO KEEP
SOME OPTIONS OPEN.
AND NAVALNY IS AGAIN MIGHT BE AN
OPTION IN THE FUTURE.
GOD KNOW'S.
SO NATURALLY, THE FACT IS THAT
NAVALNY IS STILL ALIVE AND CAN
SEND MESSAGES THROUGH